I was watching NBC and they had this
sort of informational graphics that
would slide in next to a congressman or
congressman when they were testifying or
asking a question and it would just give
you a little information about him let
you know who they are for example this
is congressman Robin Kelly hers right
there you can see they put in all this
nice information that tells you about
her time in Congress lets you know who
she is and I thought well that's pretty
useful but I noticed as I watch the
hearing and it went on and on the stats
kind of became less useful less helpful
for example congressman mark Greene of
Tennessee check it out it says right
here it slid in said yellow belt in
Taekwondo disowned his son for listening
to rap once referred to salad as french
fries for gays that was weird yeah I
kept watching I said this about
Congressman Jim Jordan he was talking
and it said with him gluten and
immigrant intolerance apartment has over
forty seven wall punch holes once put
his penis into a warm pita pocket weird
yeah well I can't really cast a stone at
him
then they had this one for Texas
congressman chip Roy
check it out says Warren in a Toyota
Corolla host of baldies bodacious
podcast ejected from t-ball games his
son wasn't even playing in and finally I
thought this was the most interesting
finally representative clay Higgins of
Louisiana check this out while they're
incarcerated wife told him don't go with
the bat
[Applause]